افاد مكتب مستشار رئاسه الاوكرانيه
ميخائيل وبدولياك للجزيره انه لم يعلن عن
بدء الهجوم المضاد او لم يعلن عن بدء
الهجوم المضاد في تصريحاته لوسيله اعلام
ايطاليه انما اكد ان الهجوم المضاد هو
سلسله من العمليات التي يتم التنفيذها
بالفعل وليس خطوه واحده ويشمل ذلك تدمير
مصادر الدعم الخلفي وعمليات الاستطلاع
وغيرها من الخطوات ياتي ذلك بعدما نسبت
وكاله روايه الاخباريه الايطاليه تصريحات
له حول اعلانه بدء الهجوم المضاد للجيش
الاوكراني قبل ايام مؤكدا ان قتالا عنيفا
يدور على طول خط الحدود
ماذا عن التطورات من الجهه الاوكرانيه
حسان
نعم عثمان عدد من التطورات على مختلف
الجبهات ولكن نبدا من اخر التطورات حيث
قبل قليل فقط نشر فيلق المتطوعين الروس
مقطع فيديو جديد يقول انه دخل الى ما
وصفها بارض الوطن مره اخرى ونشر مقطع
الفيديو الذي يظهر فيه جنديان وهما يقفان
بالقرب من احدى اللافتات التي تظهر انها
داخل منطقه تقع عند المنطقه الحدوديه
الواقعه بين بولغرد وخاركيف ولكن حتى هذه
اللحظه لا تاكيد لتاريخ التقاط هذا
الفيديو ولا تاكيد للمعلومه حول دخول
هؤلاء مره اخرى او تسللهم الى الاراضي
الروسيه ولكن هذا الحدث جرى قبل دقائق فقط
وما زلنا نتحقق من مزيد من المعلومات حول
هذه المعلومه ولكن هؤلاء
قد اطلقوا في مؤتمر صحفي يوم امس تصريحات
عده من بينها انهم اكدوا ان عملياتهم
مستمره وان ما حدث في خلال الايام الماضيه
سيحدث في مرات اخرى وفي مناطق مختلفه
وربما يكون ذلك هو ما اشار له في مؤتمرهم
الصحفيه الذي تحدثوا خلاله عن عدد من
المواقف من بينها الحديث عن الحصول او عن
الاستحواذ على
اسرى ومعدات عسكريه خلال هجماتهم هذه
الهجمات كان هناك تصريحات من الجانب
الاوكراني حول من بينها تصريح كان لافتا
خلال الليله الفائته لامين عام مجلس الامن
القومي والدفاع الاوكراني اوليكسي دانيلوف
التي قال ان على روسيا ان تعتاد على مثل
هذه الهجمات وان هذه الهجمات هي اشاره على
بدء تفكك روسيا وفق قوله
خلال تصريحات ادلى بها للتلفزيون المحلي
الاوكراني قال كذلك ان تفكك روسيا هو
لمصلحه اوكرانيا وفق تعبيره وقال ان من حق
المواطنين الروس ان يتواجدوا على ارضهم
بالطريقه التي يرونها مناسبه وكل ذلك هو
تعليق على احداث بالقرود واكد ان على
روسيا ان تعتاد على مثل هذه الهجمات وفق
تعبيره هذا فيما يرتبط بالاحداث عند
الحدود اما التطورات الميدانيه فان القصف
على
مناطق مختلفه ما زال مستمرا سواء كان عبر
القصف المدفعي والصاروخي على مناطق الجبهه
تحديدا في مناطق واقعه شرق وجنوبي البلاد
لكن كان لافتا ان نائبه وزير الدفاع تحدثت
عن تطورات بشكل واضح عند جبهه كوبيانسك
وهي المنطقه الواقعه الشرقي مقاطعه خركيف
وقالت ان التطورات
بارزه خلال الفتره هناك وان المحاولات من
جانب القوات الروسيه متواصله للتقدم عند
تلك الجبهه وان القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت
تتصدى لهذه الهجمات بالاضافه الى هجمات
عند منطقه
وايضا مناطق مارينكا وكذلك محيط منطقه
باخموت تلك المنطقه التي اكدت كذلك نائبه
وزير الدفاع ان قوات فاجنر تنسحب منها وان
الجيش
الاوكرانيه الروسيه عفوا هو الذي بدا
يسيطر على تلك المنطقه هناك مع تاكيدها ان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تقوم بهجمات
وتحاول ان تحافظ على مواقعها او مواقعها
في الضواحي منطقه بخ متافه الى الهجمات
الليليه بالمسيرات التي تقول الدفاعات
الجويه انها تتصدق شكرا